This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When a Brazilian soccer player scores a goal, the announcer starts slow. And it builds. Until it reaches a glorious crescendo. Aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa That's because soccer means so much to Brazil. How can I explain what soccer means to Brazilians without sounding corny, but I think I'm going to have to sound corny, okay? That's Fernando Duarte, a BBC journalist who wrote a book about Brazilian soccer. Soccer, or football as I call it being British, arrived in Brazil in the late 19th century. At first it was a game played in elite circles and in cities, but poor and working glass Brazilians struggled to make the game their own.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。当巴西足球运动员进球时，解说员的声音由慢变快，层层递进，直到达到一个辉煌的高潮。阿————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————————这是因为足球对巴西意味着太多。我怎么才能向巴西人解释足球的意义而不显得老土呢？但我看我不得不显得老土了，好吗？说话的是费尔南多·杜阿尔特，一位写过一本关于巴西足球的书的BBC记者。足球，作为英国人我管它叫足球，在19世纪后期传入巴西。起初，它是在精英圈子和城市里玩的游戏，但贫穷和工人阶级的巴西人努力让这项运动打上了他们自己的印记。
The only time the elites were robbed or deprived of something by the poor people or by the common folk is when football seized to be a game for the elites and it became a mass sport. Soccer eventually became so popular and beloved in Brazil that their national team soccer jersey has become as much a national symbol as the country's flag. We're gonna see many more people in Brazil wearing the shirt than waving the flag as a sense of belonging. No matter if you earn, you know, peanuts picking up old Sothecans on the street or if you're a millionaire, when you wear that shirt you're just like one of us, those shirts are extraordinary. They are scintillating. In fact, I think the word is co-rascating.
精英阶层被穷人或平民剥夺或失去某些东西的唯一一次，就是足球不再是精英的游戏，而变成了大众运动。足球最终在巴西变得如此受欢迎和受喜爱，以至于他们的国家队球衣已经成为与国旗同等重要的国家象征。我们在巴西看到更多的人穿着这件球衣，而不是挥舞国旗来寻找归属感。不管你是在街上捡旧苏打罐赚点小钱，还是个亿万富翁，当你穿上那件球衣时，你就跟我们一样，那些球衣太非凡了。它们闪闪发光。事实上，我觉得那个词叫光彩夺目。
That's the Socorita and historian, David Goldblatt. There are flashes of diamond light coming off of those shirts. to end historian David Goblah. The Brazilian soccer shirts are so iconic that non-soccer fans all over the world can often picture them, but for those of you who can't, the shirt is a bright canary yellow with green trim around the collar and sleeves. They're worn with blue shorts, a pure primary blue. Compared with other soccer jerseys, the uniform is joyful and bold. It seems to capture something essential about Brazil. But it wasn't always this way. In fact, Brazil used to play in plain, unremarkable white shirts.
那是足球作家兼历史学家大卫·戈德布拉特。这些球衣上闪烁着钻石般的光芒。致敬历史学家大卫·戈德布拉特。巴西的足球球衣是如此具有标志性，以至于全世界不看球的球迷通常也能在脑海中浮现出它们的模样，但对于那些想象不出来的人来说，这件球衣是鲜艳的金丝雀黄，领口和袖口饰有绿色边饰。它们搭配蓝色的短裤，一种纯正的原生蓝色。与其他足球球衣相比，这款队服欢快而大胆。它似乎捕捉到了巴西某种本质的东西。但事情并非一直如此。事实上，巴西过去穿的是朴素、不起眼的白色球衣。
The story of how the uniform changed goes back 70 years to an epic soccer game that Brazilians will never forget. After years of lobbying, the World Cup arrived in Brazil in 1950. At the time, the country was culturally and internationally kind of unknown. This was Brazil's big moment to show the world what it was made of. The 1950 World Cup was understood
关于队服是如何改变的故事要追溯到70年前的一场史诗般的足球赛，巴西人永远不会忘记这场比赛。经过多年的游说，世界杯于1950年登陆巴西。在当时，这个国家在文化上和国际上几乎默默无闻。这是巴西向世界展示其真正实力的绝佳时刻。1950年世界杯被
by the Brazilian population as an opportunity to say to the world, Brazil has arrived. They knew this World Cup was their chance to tell everyone. We have modernised, we have been transformed, we've moved from being an agricultural plantation economy to a new urban industrialised economy, and this is our way of showing it. The main symbol of that coming out, apart from what was happening on the soccer field, was the stadium named the Maricanar in Rio de Janeiro.
巴西人民视为向世界宣告“巴西来了”的机会。他们知道这届世界杯是他们向所有人宣告的机会。我们已经现代化了，我们已经转型了，我们已经从一个农业种植园经济体转变为一个新的城市工业化经济体，这就是我们展示这一点的方式。除了球场上发生的事情之外，这种崭露头角的主要象征就是里约热内卢的马拉卡纳体育场。
It looks like the stadium from outer space. I mean, it is this fabulous flat white concrete oval with amazing flying buttresses. Just like this huge flying saucer that had dropped down in the center of the city. But done with this sort of incredible sort of modernist elegance, I mean it was the greatest stadium built since the Colosseum. So they had the stadium, the people were behind them, the government was pushing the tournament whenever possible. Now all they needed was a successful team. The expectations were high because of this whole climate, this atmosphere of optimism. In one of their earlier games, Brazil strobe confidently onto the field in their white uniforms
它看起来像是一座来自外太空的体育场。我的意思是，这是一个极好的扁平白色混凝土椭圆形建筑，带有令人惊叹的飞扶壁。就像一个巨大的飞碟降落在城市中心。但它带有这种令人难以置信的现代主义优雅，我的意思是，它是自斗兽场以来建造的最伟大的体育场。所以他们有了体育场，人民支持他们，政府也在尽一切可能推动这项赛事。现在他们只需要一支成功的球队。由于这种整体气候、这种乐观的氛围，人们的期望很高。在他们早期的比赛中，巴西队穿着白色队服自信满满地走上球场
and proceeded to demolish Sweden 7-1. Brazil were absolutely fantastic in the opening rounds. They were slaughtering everybody, the scoring goals or over the place. They beat Spain 6-1. They also beat Mexico and Yugoslavia. The tournament was going exactly to plan. It was this whole atmosphere of like sporting bliss. exactly to plan. Because of a quirk in the tournament structure, all Brazil had to do to win the World Cup was
并以7比1大胜瑞典。巴西在小组赛中表现绝对出色。他们横扫所有人，到处进球。他们以6比1击败西班牙。他们还击败了墨西哥和南斯拉夫。比赛完全按计划进行。这是一种充满竞技狂喜的氛围。完全按计划进行。由于赛制上的一个巧合，巴西队赢得世界杯所需要做的全部事情就是
tie against Uruguay in their final game. Uruguay historically had been a really strong team, even though they're a tiny country almost 50 times smaller than Brazil. But by the time this 1950 World Cup came along, Uruguay was a waning power in soccer, so beating them or at least tying them seemed totally doable, not a problem. Still, Uruguay was no pushover, especially when they were playing against Brazil. Uruguay actually used to be a Brazilian province, so they had this chip on their shoulder about their older,
在最后一场比赛中与乌拉圭战平。乌拉圭历史上一直是一支实力强劲的球队，尽管他们是一个面积比巴西小近50倍的小国。但到了1950年世界杯时，乌拉圭已经是足坛日渐衰落的力量，所以击败他们或至少与他们战平似乎完全可行，不是问题。尽管如此，乌拉圭也不是好惹的，特别是当他们对阵巴西时。乌拉圭实际上曾是巴西的一个省，所以他们对于自己这个年长、
bigger, next-door neighbour. The whole thing of being Uruguay and going against the odds, fighting against an old colonial power, it spurred them on. Meanwhile, the whole of Rio is now thinking about just one thing, the World Cup Final. There really is mass hysteria about it. Everybody knows about it. Everyone's engaged with it. Everyone wants to go. No one can talk or think about anything else. In Brazil, people like to say that if everybody who claimed to have been in the stadium that afternoon was actually there, the stadium would have needed to be the size of the moon. And it was a big crowd. Some estimate that there were 250,000 screaming fans packed into this flying saucer stadium, which is something like 80,000 people
体量更大的邻居一直有一种怨气。乌拉圭人迎难而上、对抗老牌殖民帝国的整体心态，激发了他们的斗志。与此同时，整个里约热内卢现在满脑子都只有一件事——世界杯决赛。对此确实存在着一种集体狂热。所有人都知道这件事。所有人都参与其中。所有人都想去。没有人能谈论或思考其他任何事情。在巴西，人们喜欢说，如果那天下午声称在球场里的人真的都在那里的话，体育场得有月亮那么大。那确实是一个庞大的观众群体。据估计，有25,000名尖叫的球迷挤在这个飞碟体育场里，这比
over a capacity. And the players, when they walked out, would just hit with this wall of noise. The place is noisy, it is raucous. But in the first half, neither team scores. So the crowd was getting nervous, everybody was getting tense. Then finally, Brazil scores a goal. Just after half time, a low shot across the goalkeeper into the bottom corner of the net. And there's just this relief that surges all around the crowd, even the journalist run on and embrace the players. Because basically everyone there thinks the game is all over, that Brazil has won the World Cup. But then... you're a wise scores. About halfway through the second half. The description by whoever was there is that the stadium fell very, very nervous and this nervousness
容量超出了大约8万人。当球员们走出来时，他们简直被这股声浪墙击中了。这个地方吵闹，而且喧嚣。但在上半场，两支球队都没有进球。所以观众开始紧张，所有人都开始紧绷。然后终于，巴西队进球了。就在中场休息后，一记低射穿过门将，直奔球门死角。全场观众顿时松了一口气，甚至连记者都跑进场拥抱球员。因为基本上那里的所有人都认为比赛已经结束了，巴西已经赢得了世界杯。但随后……乌拉圭进球了。大约在下半场中段。在场所有人的描述是，体育场陷入了非常非常紧张的氛围，这种紧张感
went to the players, almost like they were losing the game. And then comes the moment that everybody will always know right. Our seedest Gigi, one of the Uruguayan wingers, gets the bull and dribbles down the right side toward the goal. And just as he's looking up to pass the bull, he notices that the goalkeeper Barbosa was actually walking to try to anticipate across, which meant Barbosa was out of position. So instead of passing the ball, Gigi shakes and scores. All of the reports talk about the most extraordinary silence in the stadium. I'll see the Gigi once said in his book, only three people in the history of the Maddaka now, silence that crowd.
传导给了球员，几乎就像他们要输掉比赛一样。然后迎来了那个所有人都将永远铭记的时刻。阿尔西德斯·吉贾，乌拉圭边锋之一，拿球沿着右路带球向球门冲去。正当他抬头准备传球时，他注意到守门员巴尔博萨其实正在往前走，试图预判一个传中，这意味着巴尔博萨失位了。所以吉贾没有传球，而是晃过防守并射门得分。所有的报道都在谈论球场里那不同寻常的寂静。阿尔西德斯·吉贾曾在他的书中说过，马拉卡纳历史上只有三个人让那个体育场鸦雀无声。
Frank Sinatra, Pope John Paul II, and me is almost like a graveyard. Some of the players don't even remember what happened. It was a state of catatonio, something like that. As you have probably guessed by now, Brazil does not manage to get another goal to tie the game. And Uruguay wins. As the game ends, the fans stream out of the stadium and back onto the streets of Rio.
弗兰纳·辛纳特拉、教宗若望·保禄二世，还有我，几乎就像墓地一样。有些球员甚至不记得发生了什么。那是一种木僵状态，诸如此类。正如你现在可能已经猜到的那样，巴西没能再进一个球来扳平比分。乌拉圭赢了。随着比赛结束，球迷们涌出体育场，回到里约的街道上。
He's almost like some kind of apocalypse happening people just when somewhere else. There was this feeling of solitude, this feeling of numbness. And Rio de Janeiro wasn't a party city on the night, on the night of July 16th, 1950. There was a lot of public crying, there's a lot of hyperbole. One Brazilian playwright caused the defeat Brazil's Hiroshima.
这几乎就像某种末日降临，人们只是迷失在别处。有一种孤独感，一种麻木感。在1950年7月16日这个夜晚，里约热内卢不再是一个派对城市。有很多人在当众哭泣，有很多夸张的言辞。一位巴西剧作家将这场失利称为巴西的“广岛”。
All right, well that's just ridiculous. Which I think is both in bad taste and in exaggeration, but people were really blind away. The recriminations came thick and fast, and soon racist accusations started to fly. Barbosa, the guy who played goalkeeper for the Brazilians, was Black. He and two other Black players on the team were scapegoated in the popular press, and Barbosa was even hassled on the street. His life was my difficult, there's a tragic story he tells later in life of hearing a woman whispering to a child, this is the man who made all of Brazil cry.
好吧，这简直太荒谬了。我认为这既没品味又夸大其词，但人们确实被彻底击垮了。指责声接踵而至，不久种族主义的指责也开始满天飞。为巴西队担任门将的巴尔博萨是个黑人。他和队里的另外两名黑人球员在通俗媒体中成了替罪羊，巴尔博萨甚至在街上受到骚扰。他的生活变得非常艰难，他晚年讲过一个悲惨的故事，听到一个女人对一个小孩子低声说：“这就是那个让整个巴西哭泣的人。”
After that, the Brazilian team didn't pick another Black goalkeeper to start in the world cup for over 50 years. And this wasn't a coincidence. After that game, Black Goalkeepers were regarded as less reliable than white ones in Brazil. Which is disgusting. But Barboso wasn't the only focus of Brazilian blame. In fact, everything about Brazilian soccer was scrutinized down to the uniforms the players were wearing. The authorities father the white shirt was cursed, and I think everybody else in Brazil did.
在那之后，巴西队在长达50多年的时间里没有再选择黑人门将作为世界杯首发。这绝非巧合。那场比赛之后，在巴西，黑人门将被认为比白人门将更不可靠。这令人作呕。但巴尔博萨并不是巴西人归咎的唯一焦点。事实上，关于巴西足球的一切都被仔细审视，甚至连球员身上穿的队服也不放过。当局认为白色球衣是被诅咒的，我想巴西的其他所有人也都是这么认为的。
And above all, there was a determination never to play in white shirts again. It was pretty unusual for a team to completely transform their uniform. Most countries have played in the same colors since the first world cup back in the early 20th century, but the Brazilians decided their uniform was a problem. So in 1953, the Brazilians soccer their uniform was a problem. So in 1953, the Brazilians
最重要的是，人们下定决心再也不穿白色球衣比赛了。对于一支球队来说，彻底改变他们的队服是相当罕见的。自从20世纪初的第一届世界杯以来，大多数国家一直穿着相同的颜色比赛，但巴西人认为他们的队服是个问题。因此，在1953年，巴西人
soccer authorities set up a competition and advertised it in a national newspaper that's distributed all over Brazil. They wanted people to write in with their designs for a new uniform. The contest had only one stipulation. The color of the uniform had to include all the colors of the Brazilian flag. Green, blue, white, and yellow, a design that would truly represent Brazil. Hundreds of people entered the contest, including this guy. My name is Ojígras C. And I'm from Jaguaron, on the board with Uruguay. Audea Garcia Schlei.
足球当局发起了一场比赛，并在全巴西发行的全国性报纸上进行了广告宣传。他们希望人们投稿设计新队服。这次比赛只有一个规定。队服的颜色必须包含巴西国旗的所有颜色。绿色、蓝色、白色和黄色，一个能够真正代表巴西的设计。数百人参加了比赛，其中包括这个人。我叫奥吉格拉斯·C，我来自雅瓜朗，与乌拉圭接壤。奥代亚·加西亚·施莱。
Ele era apenas 19 quando ele entrou a competição. Um homem que foi feito em um pouco de cidade na borda de Brasil e Uruguai. Schlei não era um designer. Ele estava fazendo um novo pape de pape de uma ilestrada. Ele disse que quando ele foi firsto sobre a competição ele pensou que isso seria tão difícil. Primeiro impressiono que eu tive que estar estava de uma bobagem. He says when he first heard about the competition, he thought it'd be too difficult. The first impression I had was that Jesus was foolish, that was ridiculous, because it's rare to have a team with four colors.
他当时只有19岁，当他参加比赛时。一个来自巴西和乌拉圭边界小镇的小伙子。施莱不是设计师。他当时正在为一份插图杂志做学徒。他说，当他第一次听说这个比赛时，他觉得这太难了。第一印象是这太荒谬了。他说当他第一次听到这个比赛时，他觉得这太难了。第一印象是这太荒谬了，因为一支球队拥有四种颜色是很少见的。
Working four colors into just the shirt would have been hard, but eventually, Schley realized he could use the whole uniform to spread out the colors. He tried blue shorts with a green shirt, a yellow and green stripe shirt with white shorts, a green and yellow stripe shirt with blue shorts. He came up with over 200 different designs. Until eventually, he had it. A gente tinha isso. Blue shorts, white socks, e um chão de chão com o treino de grão sobre o seu corpo e os leves. Ele sentiu a design de um pouco mais tarde. Ele se olhou na péssia e se olhou e se olhou na péssia de seu design,
把四种颜色融入仅仅一件球衣会很难，但最终，施莱意识到他可以用整套队服来分散这些颜色。他尝试过蓝色短裤配绿色球衣，黄色和绿色条纹球衣配白色短裤，绿色和黄色条纹球衣配蓝色短裤。他想出了200多种不同的设计。直到最后，他成功了。我们有了这个。蓝色短裤，白色球袜，还有一件带有绿色饰边的黄色球衣。他不久后感受到了这个设计。他看着这件球衣，看着他的设计，
estarei na péssia. Ele era uma. As iniciativas do meu nome e ele era indio antes foi soferst. Depois da época, ele era só um pate. O meu pate não era de agrução e eu sempre acabei de liberar o seu novo ronho que eu funcionava. After that was just a party. My feet didn't touch the ground and I was celebrating the new room where I worked. It was like something impossible had just happened. After he won, Schlagotte Bask in the glory of it all for a while.
我就要成功了。这就像是一场派对。我的双脚不着地，我在我工作的新房间里庆祝。这就像是不可能发生的事情刚刚发生了。获胜后，施莱享受了一段时间的荣耀。
He went to Rio, did an internship with the newspaper that had sponsored the contest. He even lived with the Brazilian players for a few months. But eventually, he returned to his small town, and kind of forgot about the shirt for a while. But pretty soon, the shirt was Brazil. In 1962, the Brazilians won the World Cup in Chile, and they were wearing Shlays uniform. Players like Pele wore the yellow shirt and dazzled the world with their extraordinary
他去了里约，在赞助这次比赛的报纸实习。他甚至和巴西球员一起生活了几个月。但最终，他回到了自己的小镇，把这件球衣的事淡忘了一段时间。但很快，这件球衣就成了巴西的代名词。1962年，巴西人在智利赢得了世界杯，他们穿的就是施莱设计的队服。像贝利这样的球员穿着黄色球衣，以他们非凡的
skill and beauty. Then color TV comes along and the whole world can watch Brazil in brand new Technicolor, like in the 1970 World Cup in Mexico. I was, you know, five when the 1970 World Cup was played and I saw Brazil win the 1970 World Cup in shimmering yellow shirts. Here's soccer historian David Goblaggan. For me, there's a memory there that I think lots of people have, even if they didn't see it, of dazzle, of brilliance,
球技和美感让世界惊叹。然后彩色电视出现了，全世界都可以在全新的全彩色中观看巴西队的比赛，比如在1970年墨西哥世界杯上。1970年世界杯举行时，我大概五岁，我看到巴西队穿着闪闪发光的黄色球衣赢得了1970年世界杯。这里是足球历史学家大卫·戈德布拉特。对我来说，那里有一种记忆，我认为很多人都有这种记忆，即使他们没有亲眼见过，那种耀眼、辉煌，
of amazing sort of global South sunshine, of flair. showing of flair. Where Brazil had failed in 1950, the following years saw success after success. They won World Cup after World Cup. Their yellow shirts becoming as much a hallmark as their intricate footwork and dazzling play. Shlays' design became iconic, a symbol of Brazil, full of sun and life. But for Slay, life wasn't quite living up to the image of Brazil he had created. He started working as a writer in academic. In 1964, a brutal US-backed military dictatorship took power in a coup.
那种令人惊叹的全球南方阳光、那种炫技。展现球技。巴西在1950年遭遇失败的地方，接下来的几年里迎来了接二连三的成功。他们一届又一届地赢得世界杯。他们的黄色球衣就像他们复杂的脚法和耀眼的球技一样，成为了标志。施莱的设计成为了标志性的存在，象征着阳光与生命的巴西。但对施莱来说，生活并没有完全达到他所创造的巴西形象的高度。他开始以作家和学者的身份工作。1964年，一个受美国支持的残酷军事独裁政权通过政变上台。
The new military government cracked down on the dictatorship took power in a coup. Antigue large demonstrations that greeted the now-deposed Brazilian president at Miami Airport when he- The new military government cracked down on people it considered to be subversive, including academics. Like a lot of other professors and students, Chile was arrested for basically being on the political left. When he got out of jail, he was expelled from his teaching job and was banned from leaving the country. Quando ele foi fora de gel, ele foi expelada de seu trabalho e foi banhado na cidade. Por cima, mas de qualquer maneira ultral, mano.
新的军政府对独裁政权通过政变上台进行镇压。反针对在迈阿密机场迎接现已被罢免的巴西总统的大规模示威活动时，他——新军政府对它认为具有颠覆性的人进行镇压，包括学者。像许多其他教授和学生一样，施莱因为基本上属于政治左翼而被捕。当他出狱后，他被剥夺了教职，并被禁止离开国家。当他出狱后，他被剥夺了教学工作，并被禁止离开城市。此外，但无论如何超出了，伙计。
Sim, eu estava traumatizando minha vida e meus sonhos, nós sofremos muito. E sofremos muito. O dictatório foi mais para 20 anos, mas, despitea as dificuldades de viver contra o But despite the difficulties of living under the watchful eye of the military police, Shlei became a successful writer and he developed an academic specialty. Shlei spent his life writing about the border between Brazil and Uruguay. I am a citizen who has a heart and a body divided between Brazil and Uruguay. Shlei was technically born in Brazil, but less than a mile from the border de Uruguai. Shlay foi ternamente bom em Brasile, mas menos thana mais de um ano da borda com o Uruguai. Em fato, quando ele era um jovem,
是的，我当时正在经历我生活和梦想的创伤，我们遭受了很多苦难。我们遭受了很多苦难。独裁统治持续了大约20年，但尽管在军警的严密监视下生活有种种困难，施莱还是成为了一名成功的作家，并发展出了一个学术专长。施莱一生都在书写关于巴西和乌拉圭边界的文章。我是一个心和身体都在巴西与乌拉圭之间分裂的公民。施莱技术上出生在巴西，但距离乌拉圭边境不到一英里。施莱技术上出生在巴西，但距离与乌拉圭的边境不到一英里。事实上，当他还是个年轻人时，
o seu pai foi a dar uma brilhada sobre a rava que separou o Uruguai de Brasile. Eu sou fruto. Eu sou de a era quando o brilhado era um jovem. A minha mãe foi a dar uma brilhada. Então eu sempre estava muito conectado com a Rua. Eu sempre estava muito ligado com a Rua. Shlays Experiante, comendo entre dois países,
他的父亲曾经带他在分隔乌拉圭和巴西的小溪上……我是个果实。我是当……还是个年轻人时的果实。我的母亲曾带我……所以我总是与这条街有着极深的联系。我总是与这条街紧密相连。施莱在两个国家之间的生活体验，
e seus experiências contra o rei de militares, têm ajudado a dar uma olhada para o Brasil e a nacionalismo. Achei que, até que ele estava com um chute, que poderia ser mais patrioticamente than o Brasil e o flag, ele é realmente muito ag agente de patriotismo. É uma ideia que concorre com aquelas que eu tenho a respeito... É uma ideia de competir com as pessoas que eu tenho para limitar e limitar e limitar os bordes.
以及他对抗军政府的经历，帮助他以一种全新的视角看待巴西和民族主义。我想，直到他亲历这一切，他才会意识到，可能有什么东西比国旗更能代表爱国主义，它实际上是一种极具凝聚力的爱国主义象征。这是一个与我所拥有的、关于限制和划定边界的观念相竞争的想法。
A Chile não pode ser um patriotismo brasileiro, mas o socorfan e ele não podem't help but be proud of the Brazilian team. Brazil was 5 years ago. Brazil won the championship 5 times. This is a source of pride. It's an honor for all of us. But Shlay has a secret, or at least something he never used to share with people who knew he was the designer of the famous yellow shirt. Shlei roots for Uruguay. For many in Brazil this is blasphemy, but not for him. We are one people, one border community.
施莱可能不是那种传统的巴西爱国者，但作为一个球迷，他情不自禁地为巴西队感到骄傲。巴西在5年前赢了。巴西赢了5次冠军。这是骄傲的源泉。这是我们所有人的荣耀。但施莱有一个秘密，或者至少是他以前从不向那些知道他是著名黄色球衣设计者的人透露的事情。施莱支持乌拉圭。对于许多巴西人来说，这是亵渎，但对却没有。我们是一个民族，一个边界共同体。
Even if you have two languages, the people have only one culture identity. Shlay feels culturally connected to both Brazil and Uruguay, but he ultimately had to pick one country's team to root for. So these days, when Brazil plays Uruguay, Shlay, like a lot of other soccer fans, suits up in his favourite jersey. But not the yellow shirt he designed, a sky blue one, the colour of Uruguay.
即使你有两种语言，人民也只有一种文化认同。施莱在文化上与巴西和乌拉圭都有联系，但他最终必须选择一个国家的球队来支持。所以这些天，当巴西对阵乌拉圭时，施莱和许多其他球迷一样，穿上了他最喜欢的球衣。但不是他设计的黄色球衣，而是一件天蓝色的球衣，乌拉圭的颜色。
Then he crosses the border from Brazil to Uruguay and finds some quiet bar to watch the game. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Joe Sykes with Delaney Hall and Mitt Fitzgerald, Avery Tuffleman and me Roman Morris. Technical production and mix by Sri Fusef with music by Sean Rial and Melodium. The English voiceover for the story was done by Neh Ara Ujo. Kitty Mingle is our senior editor, Kurt Kohlstedt is the digital director, and Terran Mazza is the office manager.
然后他穿过从巴西到乌拉圭的边境，找一家安静的酒吧看比赛。“99%隐形”本周由乔·赛克斯与德兰妮·霍尔和米特·菲茨杰拉德、阿弗里·图夫勒曼以及我罗曼·马尔斯共同制作。技术制作和混音由斯里·富瑟夫负责，音乐由肖恩·里尔和梅洛迪姆提供。本期节目的英文配音由内赫·阿拉·乌霍完成。基蒂·明格尔是我们资深编辑，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，特兰·马扎是办公室经理。
We'd like to thank Alex Belloes for his help. Alex was the first English journalist to write about this story and helped point us in the right direction. Junior Mazza and Fabio Aranalde also affixed everything up in Brazil and translated our interview with Shlay. We are a project of 91.7KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook.
我们要感谢亚历克斯·贝洛斯提供的帮助。亚历克斯是第一位报道这个故事的英国记者，并帮助我们指明了正确的方向。儒尼奥尔·马扎和法比奥·阿拉纳尔德还在巴西协助处理了一切事务，并翻译了我们对施莱的采访。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的广播街。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并参与讨论。
You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and have a nice subreddit too. But this week we have two articles by Kurt about the naming, numbering, and categorization of colors on our website. It's 99PI dot org. Radio Tumpia. The realization of colors on our website, it's 9ipi.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在推特上@罗曼·马尔斯，或在节目账号@99PI org与我们互动。我们在 Instagram、Tumblr 上都有账号，还有一个很棒的 Subreddit。但本周我们在网站上有库尔特撰写的两篇文章，关于颜色的命名、编号和分类。网址是 99PI点org。广播塔皮亚。关于我们网站上颜色的实现，网址是 9ipi.org。广播塔皮亚。来自 PRX。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。